we now project the Republicans in the
next Congress will be the majority here
to see some blue dogs picked off tonight
we're not having the same purification
process happen on the left as you are on
the right it's a purge when I take away
how we began the night to where we are
now there is a bloodbath going on right
out here come on the American people
have spoken loud and clear tonight and
they said you've not listened Washington
the ballots are counted and a whole new
brand of hope and change is coming to
Washington DC but forget about what
you're hearing on the cable y actions
this election is no big deal for at
least three reasons we're still on the
fast track to the poorhouse the
Republicans talk a good game about
smaller government but under their own
much-ballyhooed pledge to America the
GOP pledges only to spend virtually the
same amount of money as the Democrats
nobody but nobody is willing to talk
about foreign policy and ending the
warfare state Barack Obama is following
George Bush's painfully slow exit plan
from Iraq and he's tripled down in
Afghanistan and the only folks more into
increasing defense spending are the new
arrivals in Congress when it comes to
social issues nobody's worse than
liberals except for conservatives Obama
and the Democrats have spent more time
hectoring us to eat our vegetables than
they have repealing Don't Ask Don't Tell
pushing immigration reform or ending
drug prohibition but don't look for the
new crew in town to push for increased
personal autonomy or social tolerance
anytime soon but let's look on the
bright side we don't have to go through
this for another two years for reason TV
I'm Nicholas
you